je suis un monstre la pire des punitions
pour moi c'est d'être encore vivant
déclaration en forme d'aveu signée jean
claude romand l'une des affaires les
plus incroyables de ces dernières années
roman se disait médecin chercheur à l'om
est-ce à genève
en fait il ne dépassait pas la frontière
il restait dans sa voiture c'est quand
même un acteur de première force pour
tromper autant de monde pendant aussi
longtemps
[Musique]
quand quelqu'un mène une double vie
voyez normalement il est il est d'un
côté bon bourgeois respectable de
l'autre il est dingue ce ter travesti
dans un cabaret trafiquants de quelque
chose en sait quelque chose comme ça lui
7 7 7 face à du docteur roman ne
recouvrait rien du tout c'est dire que
ces journées se passait une fois conduit
les enfants à l'école dans sa voiture
sur des parkings d'autoroutes dans des
cafétérias dans une espèce de vide et de
béances total
[Musique]
on donne à voir quelque chose un
personnage une tragédie moderne qu'est
ce qui se raconte un peu sur la folie
des êtres sur la folie des hommes
[Musique]
ce film l'a dit très clairement que le
travail n'est pas forcément un
épanouissement et que pour certains le
travail est au contraire une aliénation
et ne sera jamais qu'une aliénation
[Musique]